i now get it  i i get what a big hit it was i mean i  i didn't really understand the whole  like before  sons michael i was oh you're you're the  guy from black hawk down oh you're that  guy from open range oh you're the guy on  goon the last boy's scout yeah the last  boys you're that guy but then you do  a show like sons for me  and the the level of what a hit that  thing was and what a crazy show it was i  became kim coates so i i think after  watching the shows now that theo and i  have done i now understand the  incredible  fandom that we and you know i don't know  if you know this michael but sons is one  of the only shows ever that our our our  ratings never went down they they only  went up like up and up they never  plateaued they never they just went up  from season one to two all the way  so